[MUSIC PLAYING]
MINHAN XIA: Good
afternoon, everybody.
Welcome to our breakout session.
My name is Minhan.
I'm a software engineer on the
Kubernetes Engine Networking
team.
So we're here to talk about
container native load balancing
on Kubernetes engine.
We have three items
on the agenda.
First, how Google
Cloud treats containers
as first-class loader
balancer endpoints.
And second, how Kubernetes
engine natively supports
advanced level seven
functionalities.
And finally, we have
a surprise session
with something coming soon.
In 2015, Kubernetes
1.0 was launched.
Google brings its
container experience
of over a decade
to the industry.
As an open source
project, Kubernetes
focused on portability.
It uses the lowest common
denominator technology.
That includes load balancing.
In 2015, most load
balancers only
work with virtual
machines and bare metals.
They do not support
containers natively.
Load balancing
solutions for Kubernetes
usually involve
some kind of proxy
to pass traffic from the load
balancer to the container.
In summary, when
Kubernetes was born,
load balancing solutions
was not optimized.
Imagine you are a customer
with multi-tier application.
I have my project
on Google Cloud.
I have my virtual
network in my project.
I have my Kubernetes
engine cluster
running in my virtual network.
I have my workloads
running in the cluster.
Now, how do I expose my
services to the internet?
The answer is the Kubernetes
service abstraction.
So the Kubernetes service
abstractions provide
two major functionalities.
First, it selects a group of
backend using label selectors.
Second, it provides
static access point
to these backend pods.
On the left, there's a
sample service specification.
Its name is my service.
It selects pods with
label key equals to app
and value equals to MyApp.
It exposes port 80, and
its type is ClusterIP.
For external traffic
in particular,
there's node port type service,
and there is load balancer type
service.
Logically, the
diagram in the middle
represents how
the traffic flows.
The traffic first arrives
at the service abstraction,
represented by the red icon.
And then the service
will deliver the traffic
to one of the backend pod
represented by the blue icons.
On top of service, there's the
Ingress resource in Kubernetes.
It represents level
seven load balancer.
A node port type service
allocates a static port
across all cluster nodes.
Traffic flowing to the node
port on any VM or any node
will be forwarded to
one of the backend pod.
This model is very
easy to understand.
There's no external dependency.
User just need to run the
standard open source kube-proxy
to have this feature.
The downsides are obvious.
There are only a limited number
of node port within a cluster.
And the clients need to
adjust to node IP changes.
And node port only provides
basic load balancing algorithm,
basically spreading
the traffic randomly.
All this results into
suboptimal load balancing.
In Kubernetes, there's a cloud
provider abstraction layer.
This layer makes it easy
to integrate Kubernetes API
with different infrastructure.
This makes Kubernetes' API
portable across platforms.
When user creates a load
balancer type service,
a real load balancer
will be provisioned.
It usually comes with
an external virtual IP.
Traffic first flow
to the virtual IP,
it arrives at the load
balancer, and the load balancer
will deliver the packet
to Kubernetes service.
In most integrations,
the load balancer
would just deliver the packet
to a node port type service.
And the service will
further deliver the packet
to the backend pods.
Kubernetes services are
level four constructs.
In order to support level
seven functionalities,
Ingress was proposed.
Ingress supports popular
level seven functionalities
like TLS termination,
URL path mapping.
There are many Ingress
implementations.
On Kubernetes'
engine, it utilize
Google Cloud load balancer
to implement the Ingress API.
Conceptually,
Ingress traffic first
arrives at the Ingress layer.
That can be a Google
Cloud load balancer.
Then the level seven
functionalities
kicks in, TLS termination
and URL path mapping.
And the load balancer
will deliver the traffic
to the corresponding service.
And the service will take
it to the backend pods.
We have briefly walk
through the Kubernetes API
constructs for load balancing.
Although the API
seems straightforward,
but the underneath data path
can be very, very complex.
To understand what is container
native load balancing,
we need to take a closer
look at the data path.
Here is a typical Ingress
setup on Kubernetes engine.
All other cloud providers
have some similar setups.
When user creates an
Ingress, Kubernetes Engine
will create a Google
Cloud load balancer.
And the Google
Cloud load balancer
will point to an instance group.
The instance group
contains all cluster nodes.
And kube-proxy is responsible
for forwarding traffic
to the actual backend pop.
The name of kube-proxy
is quite misleading.
It's not a real proxy.
It programs iptables and ask
the Linux kernel to do its job.
So this setup results in
suboptimal load balancing.
As you can see in the
animation, the blue dot
represents the incoming traffic.
Load balancer sends packet
to the virtual machine,
and kube-proxy programs
iptables to intercept traffic
from the load balancer.
Then the iptables
magic took place.
iptables randomly select
one of the backend pod,
perform network address
translation, port translation,
and finally send the packet
to the destination pod.
Because the backend pod
selection is randomized,
the iptables can select a pod
on a different node that will
result in a second network hop,
For the response packet, it will
reverse the incoming data path.
So the pod will send
out a response packet.
The packet will first arrived
in the forwarding node.
On the forwarding,
iptables and contract table
will undo all the network
address translation
and port translation.
And then the packet will return
back to the load balancer.
So with all these, it's
very, very complex.
There's a lot going on
just to deliver packet
to the container.
Now, we are proud to announce
container native load balancing
using network endpoint group
feature on Google Cloud.
Network endpoint
group feature allows
Google Cloud load balancer to
target containers directly.
Containers become
just another endpoint.
As you can see in the animation,
there's no IP table magic.
There's no proxy involved, no
need for the complex network
address translation.
And of course,
there's no second hop.
Every connection is
established directly
between the load balancer
and the backend pod.
So let us have a
side-by-side comparison.
The data path becomes
much, much cleaner.
So what difference does it make?
Network endpoint groups
makes load balancing
for containers as
efficient and as easy
as load balancing
for virtual machines.
So let's summarize.
Network endpoint groups makes
container a first class citizen
on Google Cloud load balancer.
It opens the door for native
container support for many load
balancer features such as
traffic shaping, advanced load
balancing algorithms,
and many more.
Take traffic shaping
as an example.
Without network endpoint
group, load balancers
can only do traffic accounting
per virtual machines.
With the secondary
load balancing
happen on the virtual machine,
load balancer loses track.
Switching traffic
between VMs doesn't
result in switching traffic
among the actual backend pod.
With network endpoint
group, load balancer
gains the visibility
into each traffic flowing
to every containers accurately.
Then traffic shaping is
achievable at the container
level.
Secondly, data
path is optimized.
There's no longer any proxy
between the load balancer
and the backend pod.
That eliminates the
second network hop.
This reduces the latency
and removes the overhead
for the complex network
address translation and results
as a predictable
network performance.
Finally, tools that integrate it
with Google Cloud load balancer
gets visibility at the
container level automatically.
Load balancer health check can
retrieve accurate health status
per container.
Without network endpoint
groups, load balancer
sends the health check
to the virtual machines,
and virtual machines force
the health check request
all over the place.
That makes the health
check result unreliable.
With all that, I would like to
introduce my colleague, Manjot.
[APPLAUSE]
MANJOT PAHWA: Thank
you, Minhan, for making
load balancing boring again.
[LAUGHTER]
Minhan just gave us an overview
of how our load balancing is
becoming more container native.
I will now touch upon how
our network services are also
becoming more container native.
Google Cloud Platform
Network Services
have the mission
to deliver services
that are smart, secure, and
modern on the Google Cloud
platform and other clouds.
We bring these strengths
to your Kubernetes Engine
deployments via Ingress
and a host of other feature
improvements.
We all know that
Ingress is your one stop
shop for configuring
all your L7 needs,
including your global HTTPS
Google Cloud load balancer.
Up until now, you could
set your host path
routing rules via
Ingress to be set up
at the HTTPS Google
Cloud load balancer using
Kubernetes' native Ingress API.
We have been working
at Kubernetes Engine
to bring Kubernetes
Engine networking at par
with Compute Engine and
establishing containers
as first class endpoints.
With these changes, you will
be able to use the Kubernetes
Ingress API to configure
L7 security, authorization
for your employees, and
use a globally distributed
caching infrastructure.
Configure security policies
for defense at scale
against distributed
denial of service attacks
with cloud armor using
Google's global infrastructure
and security systems.
Use cloud armor in your
Kubernetes Engine deployments
to protect against malicious
attacks at the edge,
and restrict access
to the load balancer.
I would recommend going to
the session on Cloud Armor
by Prajakta.
Control access to your
internal applications
at application level granularity
using identity-based access
control with
identity-aware proxy.
Cloud IAP, or
identity-aware proxy,
lets you establish a
central authorization
for all your applications
accessed by HTTPS so that you
can use an application-level
access control instead
of the older network-level
firewalls, which gives you
an all-or-nothing
access-level granularity.
Third, leverage a
globally distributed
caching infrastructure
for all your low latency
applications using Cloud CDN.
Caching content at the edges of
Google's network infrastructure
using our over 90 CDN
locations will provide you
faster delivery of your
content to your users
while reducing serving costs.
Together, with the
above capabilities,
you can build applications
on Kubernetes engine
that are smart,
secure, and modern.
We will demonstrate
the integration
of these new
capabilities and how
Ingress on Google
Cloud Platform becomes
the single pane of configuration
for all your L7 needs.
Let's jump into a little more
detail on how we can do that.
So we introduced a new concept
called the BackendConfig.
But before we do
that, let's jump
into a little more history.
As you might already know,
Kubernetes Ingress API
is the open source
and portable way
to express your
L7 configuration.
Since it was meant
to be portable,
the only way to have
provider-specific information
was through Ingress Annotations.
This made the integration of
new features either dependent
on the approval
of the community,
affecting the speed of
overall development,
or an overpopulation
of annotations
on your Ingress definition.
Maintaining this
delicate balance
between provider-specific
information
and an Ingress portability is
not an easy question to answer.
So BackendConfig aims to
address exactly that problem.
We introduce BackendConfig
to specify configuration
on a per service basis.
Use BackendConfig for your
Google Cloud Platform network
services like Cloud Armor,
identity-aware proxy, and cloud
CDN to begin with.
BackendConfig is a new
Kubernetes custom resource
that is a Kubernetes
native concept
and is specific to
Google Cloud Platform.
BackendConfig lets you
specify configuration
for all your services
without the need of polluting
your Ingress definition
with too many annotations
as was the case in
the past, and which
makes your ingress
definition non-portable.
This simplifies your experience
with the Ingress API.
There's native integration with
all the GCP network services,
giving you a host of benefits.
And service configuration
becomes a first-class concept.
You have the flexibility
to specify configuration
pertaining to a single service
rather than an all-or-nothing
for your whole deployment.
You can hook up your
service definition
using BackendConfig to use
all these network services.
Now, let's move on to
some of the new features
that we have for Ingress on
the Google Cloud Platform.
Minhan already mentioned
that Ingress can
be used for TLS termination.
Today, we announce the
availability of multiple TLS--
multiple SSL certificate support
through your Ingress definition
instead of the older way of
bundling multiple domains
into a single certificate
or having multiple Ingress
definitions that adds overhead.
We also try to ensure
at Kubernetes Engine
that your Ingress remains
competitive in the integration
of new protocols
and new technology.
Ingress now supports
HTTP/2 protocol,
which is designed to
improve performance
over its predecessor, which
is the HTTP/1 protocol.
Support for HTTP/2
enables you to use
gRPC, which is an open source
framework for remote procedure
calls based on the
HTTP/2 standard.
gRPC enables you
creation of performant,
scalable APIs and micro services
in many programming languages
and platforms.
To summarize what we
have mentioned until now,
we bring you a host
of new capabilities
and features to configure
at L7 via Ingress
on the Google Cloud Platform--
the concept of
BackendConfig, which
lets you set configuration
on a per service
basis without the need
of polluting your Ingress
definition with too
many annotations
and gives you flexibility to
specify things on a per service
basis rather than for
your whole deployment;
native integration with Google
Cloud Platform's network
services, which lets you get
a host of benefits, including
security at L7
using Cloud Armor,
identity-based access
control for your applications
via identity-aware proxy, and
a globally distributed caching
infrastructure using cloud CDN;
Ingress on the Google Cloud
Platform also lets you
use multiple SSL certs
for your deployment and use
new protocols such as HTTP/2
and gRPC.
With that, I'll
hand over to Bowei,
who is the Kubernetes
Engine TL, to show
you a host of new features.
[APPLAUSE]
BOWEI DU: OK, hello.
Thanks, Manjot.
So Kubernetes Engine makes it
easy to create Google Cloud
load balancers.
And it's full of
features as you've
seen in the previous slides.
But we've heard
lots of questions
about how to extend your
applications using Ingress
across multiple
clusters, whether it's
for fault tolerance or
to optimize latency.
And what I'm going to show you
is a sneak peek of something
that we're currently working on.
So suppose you create an app.
You deploy it on Kubernetes
Engine in North America,
and you have users
coming to your cluster.
Now, your app gets very popular.
Actually, popular
all over the world.
Now you have users coming
from London, Singapore,
all over from Europe, Asia.
But your application
is still being served
from a North American cluster.
Note that the Google
Cloud load balancer
will terminate your
connections at the Google edge.
You'll see there's a Google
edge in North America, Europe,
and Singapore, which
gives your users
the benefits of low latency
protocol termination.
However, the application
will be still served
from your North
America location,
so the end-to-end application
latency may be higher
for some users in the world.
Now, today you can geolocalize
your application by using DNS.
With this setup, you can create
an Ingress for each cluster
you're serving in
the region that you
want it to serve and then
have a different VIP for each
and put that virtual
IP in your DNS record.
While this gives you
geolocalization, as you know,
DNS has suboptimal load
balancing and failure
over characteristics.
In addition, you
need to maintain
multiple copies of
the Ingress resource
and synchronize them
among your clusters.
Also, you need to
set up geo-DNS.
So we are excited to
announce an upcoming feature
in Kubernetes Engine,
which is multi-cluster and
multi-regional Ingress support.
With this feature, you'll
be able to write one Ingress
definition and use Google
Cloud load balancer
to distribute traffic among the
clusters from a single anycast
IP.
Now, as your user base
expands, say, worldwide,
you will be able to add
clusters in each region
where you will have
users, following
your user population as needed.
As you see from the
diagram, there'll
be a single virtual IP that will
be programmed into your DNS.
And traffic from
each of your clusters
will be routed to
the closest one.
In fact, if capacity is exceeded
or if a cluster goes down,
your user will be
routed to the next best
destination automatically
as failure is detected.
Now, actually, let's
take a hands-on look
at some of the details
about how this will work.
So, give me one second.
OK, so here we have
a dashboard that
is wired up to a live
instance of the multi-cluster,
multi-regional Ingress.
And as you see, following
the workflow from before,
we have a North
American cluster.
And most of our users
are from North America,
so they experience
acceptable latency.
We have a few users from
Asia, but not too many.
Now, as we increase the
traffic, because our app got
super popular, we got a
lot of users from Asia.
But you'll notice that they're
still hitting the North
American cluster.
With multi-cluster and
multi-regional Ingress,
we can actually add a cluster.
You see that we added
a cluster in Asia,
but we haven't
updated the routing.
Now, finally, we will
update the routing
so that this cluster is
included in the load balancer.
And as you see,
the users in Asia
will go to the Asia cluster.
And the users in North America
will go to the North America
cluster.
Now, let's poke a little bit
in terms of what this actually
looks like.
So here is the Ingress
definition for this setup.
You notice that it is just
the vanilla Kubernetes Ingress
definition.
And in fact, when
you go and look
at your network service
in Google Cloud UI,
you'll see that it sets
up a single virtual IP.
And the difference is you
have two backend services, one
of them in Asia and one
of them in North America.
Finally, let's see what
happens for your users, right?
Your users, we have
clients in Asia,
and we have clients
in North America.
So here's an access log
that's been aggregated
across the clusters,
showing where
the user request was coming from
and which cluster is served.
And as you can see, requests
coming from North America
are served by the
North American server,
and requests coming
from Asia are being
served by the Asia cluster.
Now, switching back
to the presentation.
OK, so what are the benefits
of multi-cluster and
multi-regional support?
So notice, you have a
single configuration
for your global applications.
You will use a single
standard Ingress definition
that you already use to
define your HTTP applications.
This definition will
be used to configure
a global multi-cluster
Google Cloud load balancer,
giving you one place for
configuration and status.
The multi-cluster,
multi-regional Ingress
will use network endpoint
groups to address your cluster
endpoints.
And as you saw earlier, this has
all the advantages of container
native load balancing.
You have accurate health
checks, better load balancing
algorithms, and optimal
network performance.
And finally, the most
straightforward point, you
have geographical load
balancing and high availability.
And using this feature will
make your Kubernetes apps
and services
globally distributed.
So as you saw in
this talk, there's
a little bit of history
about where container load
balancing was and
some indications
of what we think the
final form should be.
And the final form should
be container native load
balancing.
What is container
native load balancing?
First and foremost, it
means that containers
have optimal network transport.
Load balancers are
container aware.
There should be no difference
whether your workload
uses containers or VMs.
It should just work.
Second, your container workloads
can use Google Cloud load
balancer feature set.
For example, security, caching,
authentication in a Kubernetes
native way, using Kubernetes
resources and configuration.
Finally, coming soon,
Kubernetes engine
will support extending
load balancing
across multiple
clusters in regions,
giving your applications global
reach and high availability.
We want to make it so that
any choice of technology,
whether it's containers or VMs,
runs the best on Google Cloud.
And container native
load balancing
is a piece of that puzzle.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]